[Musik]
zu lange zu schlechte luft der
europäische gerichtshof verurteilt
deutschland wegen zu hoher
stickoxidwerte neue koalition in israel
acht parteien einigen sich auf ein
regierungsbündnis ohne langzeit
ministerpräsident netanjahu steht es
noch nicht aufgeben und einer medaille
ein stückchen näher
bei der eishockey wm gewinnt deutschland
im penaltyschiessen gegen die schweiz
und zieht ins halbfinale ein
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wir
auch wo die zehn ist rennsport hallo und
guten abend
die deutsche umwelthilfe spricht von
einer ohrfeige für die bundesregierung
der europäische gerichtshof hat
deutschland wegen zu schlechter luft
verurteilt in vielen städten wurden die
grenzwerte für stickoxide deutlich
überschritten und so die kritik der
richter
es wurde zu wenig dagegen getan
allerdings bezieht sich das urteil auf
die jahre 2010 bis 16
mittlerweile ist die luft sauberer
geworden woran es liegt zeigten leihen
muss die luft um diese messstation in
kiel war jahrelang eine der
schlechtesten in ganz deutschland der
zulässige stickoxid grenzwert wurde noch
2009/10 klar gerissen
doch schon 2020 sei das deutlich besser
aus durch die klagen die gekommen sind
durch die luftreinhaltepläne die
aufgestellt wurden durch mehr messungen
und da mussten wir uns bewegen wir haben
uns bewegt das ist ja auch im sinne von
klimaschutz von verkehrswende insoweit
schlagen wir da auch verschiedene
fliegen mit einer klappe nicht allen ist
das geglückt sechs deutsche städte
stehen immer noch auf der stickoxid
sünderliste für sie könnte das urteil
des europäischen gerichtshofs neue
auflagen zur folge haben
härtere konsequenzen dürften allerdings
ausbleiben
für dieses urteil sind vor allem
landesregierung egal ob schwarz rot oder
grün geführt verantwortlich sie haben
jahrelang auf zeit gespielt und zu
lasten der gesundheit der bevölkerung
recht gebrochen
vor allem wegen erfolgreicher klagen von
umweltverbänden hat sich inzwischen aber
doch einiges für bessere luft getan
deshalb muss deutschland wohl auch keine
strafe an die eu zahlen wie sehr die
luftqualität sich verbessert hat zeigen
die zahlen der letzten zehn jahre der
anteil der messstationen mit zu hohen
stickoxidwerte es drastisch
zurückgegangen den größten anteil daran
haben moderne diesel der abgasnorm 6d
sagt das umweltbundesamt
wir sehen und das spricht dafür dass es
vor allen dingen die flotten erneuerung
ist wir sehen die rückgänge jetzt auch
in den wohngebieten und auch in
ländlichen bereichen also fernab von der
eigentlichen quelle nämlich dem
straßenverkehr in den städten und
ballungsräumen in besonders belasteten
städten muss man mehr tun so wie in kiel
auf der problem straße b 76 werden lkw
umgeleitet es gibt mehr tempolimits und
elektromobilität und rund um den
messstationen mit der schlechten luft
versuchen sie es zusätzlich mit großen
luftfilter anlagen in israel hat ein
ehemaliger fernsehmoderator das erreicht
was nur wenige für möglich hielten
oppositionsführer rapid hat in der nacht
eine beispiellose koalition zusammen
gebracht aus ultra rechten linken und
erstmals auch aus einer arabischen
partei sie ein vor allem ein ziel sie
wollen nach zwölf jahren das ende der
ära netanyahu einläuten aus tel aviv
michael b warum ein historischer moment
die koalition der einheit steht in
wahrheit eine der gegensätze links der
liberale ja eher lapidar neben der
rechtsnationale naftali bennett und der
arabisch islamistische man so abbas
mit ihren unterschriften besiegeln sie
und fünf weitere parteien das bündnis
den präsidenten meldet rapid erst kurz
vor zwölf voll zu alle parteien haben
unterschrieben dass sie mich und diese
koalition tragen also informiere ich sie
hiermit dass ich erfolgreich eine
regierung gebildet habe historisch auch
dass eine arabische partei erstmals
regierungspartner wird für uns geht es
um bildung arbeitsplätze die
legalisierung arabischer wohnungen und
um die bekämpfung von kriminalität und
gewalt in den arabischen gemeinden in
diesem vertrag stehen viele dinge die
den arabischen teil der gesellschaft
voranbringen
bei den arabischen bürgern löst das
vorsichtige hoffnung aus ohne abbas gebe
es keine regierung dies ist etwas gutes
für uns für araber und für juden und es
erspart und seine fünfte waren gemischte
gefühle bei vielen juden
ich glaube nicht dass diese regierung
lange hält vielleicht ein jahr sie ist
zu zersplittert
es wird sehr schwierig werden aber wenn
diese regierung durchhält wird sie
israel verändert
schon jetzt stehen die neuen für neue
bescheidenheit rapid lässt bennett den
vortritt als premierminister obwohl der
nicht mal halb so viele stimmen hat dass
manche das ende der ära netanjahu und
seine baldige verurteilung feiern ist
aber verfrüht das neue bündnis hat
denkbar knapp nur eine stimme mehrheit
netanjahu setzt alles daran seine gegner
zu spalten
alle knesset mitglieder die mit den
stimmen von rechts gewählt wurden
twittert er müssen sich gegen diese
gefährliche links regierung stelle
schon nächste woche könnte es in der
knesset zum showdown kommen
michael bewerunge in tel aviv kann
netanjahu diesen machtwechsel noch
verhindern
also nicht ein jahr hat zumindest
durchaus noch einige pfeile im köcher
das geht so weit dass er sogar den rabbi
eines der wackelkandidaten in der
koalition angerufen haben soll und ihn
gebeten haben soll
doch in netanjahus sinne einzuwirken
dass er sich anders verhält und die
erste machtprobe im parlament die
koalition hatte und versucht hat mit
ihrer denkbar knapp mehr hat den
parlamentspräsidenten vom die code
abzuwählen die ist krachend gescheitert
weil eben jener watte kandidat in
letzter minute seine zustimmung
zurückgezogen hat die taktik metern
jahres wird sein so lange wie möglich
auf zeit zu spielen die abstimmung über
die regierung zu verzögern um doch noch
einen keil in dieser koalition zu
treiben die stets war aber im amt
bestätigt ist sie noch lange nicht
live aus tel aviv michael bewerunge
vielen dank kommen wir zur corona lage
in deutschland das robert koch institut
meldet 4640 neue infektionen innerhalb
eines tages das sind 1673 weniger als
vergangenen donnerstag 166 todesfälle
kamen hinzu
die bundesweite incidents sinkt wieder
auf jetzt 34,1 das ist der niedrigste
wert seit mitte oktober
wir wollen mit wumms aus der krise
kommen so kündigte finanzminister scholz
vor genau einem jahr die korona hilfen
der bundesregierung an
dieses juni paket umfasste 130
milliarden euro geld bekamen besonders
belastete firmen und kommunen ein
kinderbonus und die vorübergehend
niedrigere mehrwertsteuer sollten den
privaten konsum ankurbeln
war das nun wurms genug dass bohnsack es
ist klar dass das ganze eine mutige
antwort braucht um mit wumms aus der
korona krise zu kommen
es waren große ankündigungen und die
koalition nahm viel geld in die hand die
bilanz heute fällt bei den regierenden
erwartungsgemäß positiv aus dadurch dass
wir dieses viele geld eingesetzt haben
ist es gelungen die wirtschaft zu
stabilisieren wir sind viel besser durch
die krise gekommen als alle vorher
gesagt haben 130 milliarden euro um die
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen folgen der
pandemie abzufedern
ein erfolgreiches instrument das
kurzarbeitergeld
ohne dieses kurzarbeitergeld werden
viele von diesen menschen entlassen
worden
in den usa beispielsweise sind auf dem
höhepunkt der korona krise mehrere
millionen menschen arbeitslos geworden
das alles hat in deutschland in dieser
form nicht statt von zum resümee gehört
für die opposition aber auch dass längst
nicht alles reibungslos lief die
schleppende auszahlung der
wirtschaftshilfen zum beispiel habe
viele unternehmen in bedrängnis gebracht
die bilanz fällt sehr gemischt aus die
fehler der schleppenden auszahlung der
hilfen müssen unbedingt in diesem jahr
verhindert werden
deshalb fordern wir statt bürokratie
dschungel die einfache auszahlung der
hilfen über die finanzämter experten
fordern dass die regierung ihre
finanziellen kraftanstrengungen nicht
reduzieren dürfe im gegenteil ein
weiteres konjunkturprogramm ist
notwendig ich würde mir wünschen dass es
einen viel stärkeren fokus auf
zukunftsinvestitionen hat und eben auch
auf die soziale komponente um soziale
polarisierung in deutschland zu
vermeiden es wird wohl noch einige
anstrengungen und viel geld kosten um
deutschland nach der pandemie zukunft
zu machen die wirtschaft springt also
gerade wieder an die weltkonjunktur
insgesamt erholt sich von corona das
kurbelt auch die nachfrage deutlich an
bei den lieferketten allerdings hapert
es fehlt an material ob stahl
elektronische komponenten oder auch
schrauben und das bekommen langsam auch
die konsumenten zu spüren
peter böhme wenn georg beckers durch
sein fahrradgeschäft in mönchengladbach
geht dann mit sorgenfalten die lücken im
verkauf nehmen zu immer größere
lieferprobleme bei den herstellern der
rat boom freute ihn natürlich aber
mittlerweile gibt es sogar bei
luftpumpen engpässe ich sehe mit
schrecken in den herbst wenn wirklich
die regale leer sind und keine ware mehr
verfügbar ist dann die neue ware ist ja
auch noch nicht in zulauf die wird erst
in späten herbst kommen oder ins
frühjahr kommen und was bis dahin ist
wir haben alle in der branche etwas
angst anderes beispiel schrauben klein
und doch unverzichtbar
auch hier lange lieferzeiten im letzten
jahr drei bis sechs monate aktuell
warten die händler bis zu einem jahr auf
ware aus fernost löcher in den hoch
lagern und teure frachtraten vor einem
jahr 800 dollar für einen container
derzeit geht's richtung 7.000 wir stehen
vor einem beispiellosen chaos weil wir
einfach die schrauben nicht mehr an
kriegen die wir für unsere kunden
brauchen und die kunden brauchen sie um
wiederum ihre produkte fertigzustellen
fahrräder solaranlagen spülmaschinen die
wir die sie und ich dann am ende kaufen
möchten und aber nicht kriegen wenn
keine schrauben da sind weltweit hunger
auf material und rohstoffe weil weltweit
nach corona die volkswirtschaften wieder
anspringen auch die deutsche doch das
problem im letzten jahr hielt sich eine
verunsicherte deutsche wirtschaft mit
bestellungen zurück andere länder waren
schneller wieder an
nun fällt es den unternehmen teilweise
auf die füße weil sie sich bei den
bestellungen hinten anstellen müssen wie
zum beispiel hinter china und den usa
denn diese beiden länder haben große
konjunkturpakete aufgelegt die
konjunktur brummt da und dementsprechend
werden da jetzt für einige rohstoffe hin
geliefert und die deutschen unternehmen
müssen höhere preise zahlen und geduld
haben manche kunden bei gearbox warten
über zwei jahre auf ihr schickes neues
fahrrad
welche konsequenzen zieht die welt aus
der pandemie
darüber haben die g7 gesundheitsminister
in england beraten
tagungsort die universität oxford wurde
impfstoff von astrazeneca mit entwickelt
wurde
dort ging es auch um die frage wie
pandemien künftig gemeinsam abgewehrt
werden können
außerdem mahnte gesundheitsminister
sparen corona impfstoffe müssten
weltweit solidarischer verteilt werden
aktuell sind in nordamerika 38 prozent
der bevölkerung mindestens einmal
geimpft und in europa 32 prozent dagegen
sind es in afrika gerade mal knapp 2
prozent in etwa einem monat soll die
bundeswehr aus afghanistan abgezogen
sein
zurück bleiben hunderte afghanen die
deutschen truppen vor ort unterstützten
sie fürchten jetzt die rache der taliban
und damit um ihr leben
im april hatte verteidigungsministerin
kramp karrenbauer versprochen die
einheimischen helfer nicht schutzlos
zurückzulassen
doch hoffnung auf eine ausreise gibt es
nur für ortskräfte der vergangenen zwei
jahre
katrin eigendorf masar i scharif
nordafghanistan
wie überall im land hat sich auch hier
die sicherheitslage dramatisch
verschlechtert ach mazana die fürchtet
den tag an dem die bundeswehr
afghanistan verlässt
acht jahre war er übersetzer für die
deutschen für die taliban ein verräter
wir verlangen von deutschland nicht mehr
als dass sie unser leben schützen
wir haben ihre mission in afghanistan
erfolgreich gemacht nun hilft bitte uns
bis zum vierten juli plant die
bundeswehr abzuziehen
die verlegung von militärtechnik läuft
auf hochtouren
zurück bleiben hunderte afghanische
ortskräfte die opfer von
vergeltungsschlägen der taliban werden
könnten
sie benutzten diese menschen um eine
botschaft zu senden und den leuten angst
zu machen davor mit dem westen zu
kooperieren achmer zahl traut sich nicht
mehr aus dem haus
auch er hat als übersetzer für die
bundeswehr gearbeitet sein antrag auf
ein visum wurde abgelehnt weil sein
vertrag vor über zwei jahren endete auf
eine sehr grausam so einfach abschießen
gegen deine koffer packen
80 prozent der afghanischen ortskräfte
wollen ihr land verlassen
während großbritannien und die usa
planen möglichst viele visa auszustellen
liegt deutschland die würden hoch dabei
drängt die zeit
dänemark verschärft seine
flüchtlingspolitik weiter asylsuchende
dürfen künftig ohne verfahren in länder
außerhalb der eu abgeschoben werden dort
sollen sie dann warten bis über ihren
antrag entschieden ist
ziel der regierung sei es die zahl der
flüchtlinge auf null zu reduzieren
die eu kommission kritisierte das gesetz
nach eu regeln sei das nicht möglich
nach der havarie eines frachters vor der
küste sri lankas kämpfen die
einsatzkräfte gegen eine drohende
umweltkatastrophe marine und küstenwache
bereiten sich auf das auslaufen von öl
vor
das schiff ist teilweise schon gesunken
mehr als anderthalb wochen stand der
frachter in flammen
auch an bord salpetersäure und dutzende
container mit plastik granulat
zahlreiche strände sind bereits
verschmutzt jetzt zum eishockey rudi da
sind die fans völlig aus dem häuschen
kann man total verstehen nach einem
krimi auf dem eis dank einer imposanten
aufholjagd besiegen deutschlands
eishockey nationalspieler bei der wm die
schweiz mit 3 zu 2 und stehen erstmals
seit elf jahren im halbfinale die
entscheidung in riga fällt erst im
penalty schießen
überschwänglicher jubel nach
fantastische aufholjagd nach 20 führt
die schweiz 45 sekunden vor schluss mit
2 zu 1 als banker mit dem 2 2 doch noch
die verlängerung erzwingen
die verläuft trotz guter chancen auf
beiden seiten torlos
das elfmeterschießen des eishockeys muss
all zu entscheiden der shootout torwart
niederberger hält weiter überragend nur
zwei der ersten neun schützen treffen
ein schweizer und ein deutscher
das bedeutet wenn marcel noebels jetzt
trifft steht deutschland im wm
halbfinale
das ist der sieg und lässiger kann man
den im eishockey kam klarmachen marcel
noebels der mann um dessen einsatz die
deutschen nach verletzung so sehr
gezittert hatten entscheidet dieses
hochdramatische viertelfinale in zwölf
tagen startet die deutsche fußball
nationalmannschaft in münchen gegen
weltmeister frankreich in die em
nach dem 1 2 1 im test gegen dänemark
hofft bundestrainer joachim löw nun auf
ein erfolgserlebnis bei der generalprobe
am montag gegen lettland der kader ist
komplett
vor einer stunde sind die drei england
profis eingetroffen darunter auch kai
harbach siegtorschütze im champions
league finale
der tag stand im zeichen der
regeneration leon goretzka befindet sich
weiterhin im aufbautraining emrich an
macht nach muskelverhärtung fortschritte
als mutmacher taugte der test bei dem
florian neuhaus das 1 0 erzielte nur
bedingt die abwehr ließ nur eine chance
zu die aber führte zum ausgleich
das maß aller dinge wird sein dass wir
in der lage sind eben auch zu null zu
spielen mal gut zu verteidigen vorsprung
auch mal über die runden zu bekommen es
gab positive ansätze
doch gemessen an der chancenverwertung
war das 1 1 dann doch an negatives
testergebnis kurz vor der tour durch
europa erfolgreicher tag bislang für
deutschlands tennis spieler nach
alexander zweck stehen auch philipp
kohlschreiber und dominik koepfer in der
dritten runde bei den french open in
paris
und es hat schon einen hauch von olympia
in 18 sportarten geht es bis sonntag bei
den finales um deutsche meistertitel für
viele auch die chance sich für die
olympischen spiele in tokio zu
qualifizieren
einer der vielen höhepunkte von heute
der mehrkampf der thunerinnen es ist ihr
paradegerät für elisabeth seitz wm
dritte am stufenbarren und sie zeigt im
deutschen mehrkampf finale in dortmund
dass sie dabei zu den besten der welt
gehört am ende ihr dreiundzwanzigster
deutscher meistertitel rekord in
deutschland dahinter nur hauchdünn auf
platz 2 überraschend die starke pauline
schäfer dritte wird titelverteidigerin
sarah voss und vierte kim bui für seid
ihr achter deutscher mehrkampf titel in
zehn tagen entscheidet sich auf der
zweiten etappe in münchen ob dieses
quartett sich endgültig für tokio
qualifiziert
wie schön rats zum abschluss ich wollte
gerade noch sagen das was vom sport dann
so vielen dank
nicht überall ist heute feiertag und
nicht über alles schönes wetter die
schwüle luft entlädt sich in gewittern
wie hier im westen deutschlands
die feuerwehr musste ausrücken um keller
leerzupumpen und straßen wieder flott zu
machen und das könnte sich in anderen
regionen deutschlands wiederholen wie
gewitter weiter ziehen und was uns more
werden erwartet dazu gleich mehr von
katja unerfahren das heute journal um
viertel vor zehn mit marietta slomka
dankeschön für ihr interesse einen
richtig schönen abend noch bis morgen
wenn sie mit
[Musik]
meine damen und herren die schwülwarme
gewitter luft aus südwesten hat sich
jetzt über der westhälfte deutschlands
ausgebreitet so gab es heute schon
gewitter von cuxhaven bis nach stuttgart
und auch jetzt am abend sind noch
heftige gewitter unterwegs die werden
uns auch in den nächsten stunden
beschäftigen bis etwa mitternacht dann
allerdings lassen die gewitter nach
das ist nur noch kräftiger regen
unterwegs diese wetter können heftig
sein also mit hagel platzregen und
sturmböen verbunden sein und morgen früh
geht das im westen gleich wieder los im
laufe des tages ziehen die gewitter dann
weiter der schwerpunkt ist ein bisschen
anders der liegt mehr in der mitte und
im süden deutschlands
heute nacht wird es sehr mild bleiben in
der westhälfte da sinken die
temperaturen noch 17 bis 14 grad im
osten und am alpenrand ist es zum teil
kühler mit 13 bis 9 grad
und morgen steigen die temperaturen
verbreitet auf 25 bis 29 grad nur an der
see und am alpenrand ist es etwas
frischer und auch morgen gibt es wieder
unwetter mit hagel platzregen und
sturmböen schwerpunkt zwischen dem
sauerland und dem alpenrand im äußersten
osten merken sie davon nichts da hält
der südostwind noch dagegen am samstag
klappt das nicht mehr
dann kommen die gewitter auch im osten
an bis später wenn sie mögen